let's talk about a little bit of the
sidebar that happened alongside this
summit between Donald Trump and Kim
jong-un in Singapore you might recall
that former NBA basketball player Dennis
Rodman star rebounder for the Chicago
Bulls of the late 1990s he has a history
with North Korea he ended up in North
Korea a couple of times doing what was
being referred to as basketball
diplomacy he personally met with the
North Korean leader Kim jong-un and
there was this period during which
Dennis Rodman was actually the American
with the most first-hand knowledge of
and sort of contact with Kim jong-un and
there's a really entertaining vice
documentary where Vice travels with
Dennis Rodman to North Korea and things
go completely hilariously off the rails
during this trip and either during that
trip or a subsequent trip to North Korea
Dennis Rodman ended up getting kicked
out because of his outrageous
drunkenness and defecation in the
hallway of a Pyongyang hotel so this is
the guy that arrived in North Korea just
hours before the summit the obvious
question was would he be part of the
actual talks the answer is no I guess
Rodman was there just to lend some
support and every element of Dennis
Rodman arriving in Singapore was bizarre
first of all at the airport he was
immediately spotted wearing a bright red
make America great again hat of course
and a t-shirt advertising for pop coin
which is a crypto currency for marijuana
dealers to store money when they can't
get legal bank accounts he then gave an
unusual interview to CNN's Chris Cuomo
and he became very emotional making very
pointed assertions about Barack Obama
and other things I just couldn't
understand Chris Cuomo to his credit
doing everything he could to ask
specific questions and sort of
interesting questions in some way one
example was hey does Kim jong-un
understand English right that's an
actually interesting question I would
like to know the answer to and Dennis
Rodman just visibly getting more and
more agitated and starting to cry and I
try to do that to Obama and Obama didn't
even give me the time of day I asked him
I said I have something to say from
North Korea he doesn't brush me off but
that didn't turn me I still kept going
back I kept going back I kept going
I sold my loyalty my trustworthy to this
country and I said to everybody I said
the door will open
I remember you saying I remember you
saying it's amazing it's amazing it's
amazing when I said those things when I
said those templates when I went back
home I got souheïb impressed
there's so many Dutchman so I was
sitting up protecting everything and I
believe that our Korea and we go home
for 30 days
but I kept my head up high brother I
knew things were change I knew it I was
the only one I never had no one to hear
me I didn't know what had to see me but
I took those bullets I took all that I
took everything everyone came at me and
I'm still standing there today is a
great day for everybody SATA for Tokyo
China everything it's a great day
it is a ground a historic day so happy
right so Chris Cuomo apparently
suppressing laughter during most of the
interview how is this real life I really
don't understand this and try a Rodman I
guess the perfect Trump supporter really
glad he wore that make America great
again had their in the interview because
he's clearly a super stable genius here
and here's chris cuomo again trying to
get an answer to this question does Kim
jong-un understand English second but
let me just get an answer to this do you
think he speaks or understands English
well I think he understands business
bits and pieces if you talk about
basketball yes he understands that so
you think it's about what he wants to
talk about do you think he's studied
English all right I'll just say one
thing I think people know that Kim Yong
Yong it's not a dumb man came underneath
understand from his grandfather his
father I think that he's trying to
protect his people be trying to protect
his honor and in his up and everything
that has to do with his country but like
I said that's respect I really like
referring to Kim jong-un as Kim on young
and still no clear answers to even the
most basic questions and this went on
for 16 minutes can you imagine being
Chris Kuo
you've got to do an interview like this
where you sort of have to pretend that
Dennis Rodman is making some sense for
16 minutes and then at the end a real
message of inspiration and peace and
optimism from Dennis Rodman and
referring to Kim jong-un yet again by
another name I think three or four
different names during this interview
used in lieu of Kim jong-un by by Dennis
Rodman take a look I know a lot of
things but like I said this is Trump and
kill my news day this is the world's day
it's not my day I just came because I
wanted to see face to face in my own
yessum thank you guys for having me on
in the world thank you guys I'm gonna do
more important things down the road
please well Santa's set behind me it's
me behind me
Dennis it is good to see you got the
best Kimmy Jung is it weird the Dennis
Rodman is the American who has spent the
most time with the North Korean leader
Kim jong-un and he seems to not know the
guy's name anyway no news about whether
Dennis Rodman met with Donald Trump
after the summit and I don't know what
the hell is going on here but this is
this is 2018 and I wish I could offer
more sort of general commentary as to
what is happening in in in our on our
planet in 2018 but I can't and this is
where we are send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we will
be back back very soon after our newly
shortened commercial breaks the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad